when you're learning something new the
best way to start is always with what
you already know so let's start with
something simple something you guys can
do with your eyes shut at the moment I'm
gonna give you a problem it's a simple
problem not that shut how would you
solve it just have a look at it have a
go it won't take you long
ok so here's the problem a slight moment
of panic as you're thinking wait it's
just too easy
I wonder if this some hidden thing in
there no no that's it you shouldn't have
arrived if you went through the working
and this is a good logical detailed way
to set it out solution one solution to
three negative one you're happy with
that thumbs up yeah okay so hold on a
second performing any further
what are these core this is all I wrote
on the board what are they called we
call them simultaneous equations don't
sound anything patience yes that's
what's gonna give me my second guess
right now I want to give you a rather
more sophisticated and specific way to
describe what these are these are more
than just simultaneous equations right
so on the side of where you've done your
working here I want you to label this is
such this is more than just simultaneous
equations we would call this a system of
now it's a system because it's a
collection of interrelated parts that
work together
that's what system means but what kinds
of equations are these they're not just
any equations they have a lot in common
what kind of equations are they they're
linear very good right so can you see
why they're linear if you use these two
variables and put them on a set of axes
right in this case an actress in of the
answers right or a be X system
whichever you get straight lines not
that complicated right what would he
have to do to make them not linear
equations
you could add a power you can add in you
can add an exponential all those kinds
of things and you would not get
Strickland anymore so this is a system
of linear equations okay be happy with
that okay now how do we solve it how do
we go through this well that's not a few
things number one your goal your
endpoint it was very simple right and it
was quite straight for what were you
heading towards you just wanted what
that value was and what that value was
that was the first thing you notice that
the endpoint the goal is simple I know
where I'm going okay I would see the
method that you all used to get there
and you probably had something similar
to this even if you didn't have exactly
the same thing right
it was all using the same tools what
kinds of mathematical knowledge did you
need to know deep back what things do
you already know that allowed you to do
this I heard algebra right what else
yeah arithmetic right did you need to
know anything else really I think that
was basically year substitution I
suppose it sir is part of algebra subset
I guess okay so the method you've got is
also quite straightforward one more
thing on one of those the a and the B
write the constants that you are solving
for because that's didn't really what
they're called doesn't matter right
there on the immaterial to this solution
I could have changed the a and the B
into a C and E or an extra now why
doesn't matter they just labels right
and at the end you'll get the same
numbers whatever letters you put
whatever labels you put so I want to
take these three fans and introduce you
to another way of solving these
simultaneous equations or working out
this system of linear equations okay now
just put your pants down for a second
we're about to unlearn a new way of
doing something productive
whenever you learned something new it's
really tricky especially when you know
how to do this and you're like why
should I learn a new way of doing this
when I already have an old way okay I'm
struggling with this with my children
because they're the age where they're
like learning to write in that kind of
thing and if any of you have younger
whether sisters you know that when you
first see one of these things it's like
a baby or something the way you pick it
up is not the way you pick it up now
pick up your pen right now and maybe how
would it try a little baby or toddler
how they pick it up and this is yes
thank you very much you'd hold it like
this right cuz that's the only way you
know how that was really quick kind of
scary anyway that's okay so that's
that's the natural way right and my
children I'm trying to teach them to
hold it differently they're like why why
I know way to hold these things it works
fine and this way is awkward it gives me
cramps once you learn what you must this
grip you can do these for something